is testing the hyundai veloster today
it's the only car he knows of that has
two doors on the right
but only one on the driver's side
sound like nonsense
hyundai's designers must have had their
reasons
we'll get to that after a test drive
on its 2011 launch the sporty coupe was
available solely with a naturally
aspirated engine a year later came a
turbo option the new veloster has now
turned its focus solely to the
turbocharged variety
that makes ordering easier says mantis a
turbo engine consumes more fuel of
course but even with a very sporty
driving style you'll still stay under 10
liters per 100 kilometers and the car
does have rather sporty handling
likes how the steering wheel fits his
hands a little heftier would be nice but
it responds well and he likes the
suspension the dual clutch transmission
that has replaced the old veloster's
automatic is a little delayed in
shifting so
room for improvement there
child powers
potential
the bucket seat fits matus like a glove
he feels right at home and there's no
danger of slipping right or left but
what's it like in back
in his back seat incarnation mata says
well it's okay but there's little head
room and he's constantly worried he'll
bump his head
there is enough leg room and space to
the left but the windows are very small
the right hand window lets a passenger
look out but the left-hand one is just
big enough so that you aren't sitting
completely in the dark
the veloster's off-beat door concept
makes it seem like a mixture of coupe
sports car and compact
the handle for the rear hatch is hidden
on the c-pillar
the low-set trunk offers 320 liters of
storage space or 1015 liters with the
rear seats turned down but the loading
sill is high and that can get
impractical
the turbo logo is stitched onto the
leather seats so even inside the car you
know what's under the hood
the 1.6 liter four-cylinder turbocharged
engine churns out 137 kilowatts the 1
360 kilogram front-wheel drive car makes
the dash from zero to 108 seconds flat
hyundai claims an average fuel
consumption of 7.1 liters per 100
kilometers co2 emissions rating is 165
grams per kilometer
likes all the included extras hyundai
and most other asian manufacturers
provide the veloster has steering wheel
heating a gps navigation system and a
keyless ghost system with start stop
button
of course no car with a heated steering
wheel lacks heated seats
and it's all markedly lower priced than
the german and european competition so
what's not to like asmatas
the materials in the interior aren't
luxury leather or wood paneling but
montes thinks the interior looks good
enough along with being functional and
easy to keep clean
his alter ego in the back seat feels
cooped up by the low roof and wants out
and that's not so easy either
which brings us back to the point at the
beginning
why does the veloster have two doors on
the right
the developers wanted to build a car
that passengers could get out of more
safely and easily but matas reckons it's
at least as awkward to leave the back
seat of the three-door veloster as to
get out of a two-door vehicle
here australia
you